le chemin dans les arbres des cinq
femmes au tombeau ou encore la maternité
de mersin c'est toi qui appartiennent au
musée maurice denis à saint germain en
laye viennent d'être prêté la dernière
est parti aux états unis
on est sollicité là pour le prêt d'une
oeuvre qui s'appelle la maternité à
mersin qui est une oeuvre de maurice
denis une huile sur toile qui a été
peinte 1896 1897 et donc en fait c'est
une co organisation d'expositions aux
états unis entre les musées de cleveland
et le musée de portland
le musée maurice denis possède près de
5000 us
ces prêts sont assez courts entre les
différents établissements du monde
entier on passe une convention qui va
régir bien évidemment tout ce qui relève
à la fois des assurances bien évidemment
du transport de la sécurité et même du
climat dans lequel vont être exposées
les oeuvres et maurice denis à sa petite
notoriété à l'international
l'artiste qui est né à granville et qui
est mort à paris a vécu toute sa vie à
saint germain en laye dans les eaux nice
est aussi bien un dessinateur un
touche-à-tout en fait il est dessinateur
il est peintre il travaille aussi sur
des vitraux il écrit énormément c'est
c'est le théoricien on dit du groupe des
nabis
il a vécu quasiment toute sa vie à saint
germain en laye le musée est
actuellement fermés il doit rouvrir le
17 septembre 2021 avec une exposition
inaugurale qui vise à commémorer le 150e
anniversaire de maurice denis et les 40
ans du musée